some of the top doctors are also being
investigated for fraud what's that about
nobody I mean a huge amount of
information that we're talking about
here consumer groups say it's a big win
for transparency we're talking about
seventy seven billion dollars in
Medicaid dollars paid to eight hundred
and eighty thousand providers this is
just in 2012 and going through these
numbers with disturbing or shocking is
really you see just how much money a
select few doctors at the top made and
more than one of them has been accused
of fraud in the past so number one the
highest paid doctor by the Medicare
program in 2012 Salomon Megan he's an
ophthalmologist in West Palm Beach from
about 21 million dollars again that's
just in 2012 that is sixty four times
the average national payment to
opthamologist that year back in 2009 he
was also found to have over billed
Medicare for 8.9 million dollars and
Betty if this name sounds familiar this
is also the same doctor that contributed
to Senator Robert Menendez his campaign
hosted him on his private plane to the
Dominican Republic the senator was
accused of intervening in a Medicare
billing dispute and a port security
contract on that doctors behalf so he's
been in the news before and another
doctor in this top 10 list is actually
in jail right now dr. Farid FATA number
seven in terms of payments
he's a Michigan oncologist who got ten
million dollars again that's just 2012
he was arrested in August on charges of
fraud dating back to 2007 who was
accused by patients of administering
treatments for cancer other disorders to
patients that didn't need those
treatments here's one of his patients at
a hearing at the end of March I went to
see two different doctors one of them a
specialist but both agreed I did not
need these treatments over the course of
seven months I paid this doctor $1,500
in co-pays I later found out he had
received over $14,000 for giving me
these treatments
now Betty important to point out here
reporters were not allowed to reach out
to the doctors before this information
came out publicly I did reach out to the
doctor's this morning haven't heard
anything back yet but previously
amalgams companies lawyer did say that
he followed all of the rules in billing
for Medicare
I mentioned doctor Fattah is in prison
he's awaiting trial but he did plead not
guilty